your mission should you choose to accept
it take a deep dive into the mission
impossible franchise
the Mission Impossible television series
run on CBS from 1966 to 1973. its
opening titles became iconic for the
imagery of a fuse being lit while the
classic theme kicked into high gear
every week team leader Jim Phelps would
be told
before getting his assignment every
assignment ended with this table
self-destruct in five seconds and the
cassette would go up in smoke these days
audiences associate Tom Cruise with
Mission Impossible and fans of the
classic show with the fans memories of
Peter Graves Jim Phelps but there's a
famous face that many people may not
realize was behind the original series
the legendary Lucille Ball Mission
Impossible was produced by desilu the
production company founded by ball and
her then husband and co-star Desi arnes
in 1966 Bal and her company sets up
Mission at CBS and a little sci-fi
series named Star Trek at NBC and both
shows gave Bard greater clouds in the
industry as a producer mission was a
bigger hit in the ratings and Trek
although Trek of course became a big
cold phenomenon in reruns the mission
impossible films that only have the
major star power of Cruz but they also
have great directors at the helm and
some of the best writers in the business
the first mission is credited to David
cope Stevens alien and Robert Downey who
who wrote one of the best films of the
70s Chinatown Tony came back for the
second mission and Hollywood Wonder kind
J.J Abrams came aboard to write and
direct the third film Brad Bird known
for helming animated Classics like the
iron Giants and the Incredibles made his
live-action directing debut with Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol since then
cruises had a steady partnership with
Christopher Macquarie who co-wrote one
of the best crime Thrillers of the 90s
The Usual Suspects however Macquarie had
his first brush with Mission Impossible
when he joined Ghost Protocol for some
uncredited rewrites his involvement
didn't stop there and he has been in the
director's chair for all of the mission
films since Rogue nation in addition
McCrory co-wrote the script for top gun
Maverick which became one of the biggest
box office smashes of 2022 and is also
done in credited script doctor work
McCrory also isn't against flying by the
seat of his pants since he boarded
Mission Impossible Fallout before a
script had even been finished according
to the Hollywood Reporter the shoot
began with 33 pages of Scripps and
Macquarie and Cruz improvise from there
as mcrory said the finished screenplay
actually confines and limits all I
really need to know is where is the
location and what assets need to be
there on that day including Vehicles
props sets and actors and that is all we
are going to say about that much of the
cast of the original Mission Impossible
TV series were around when the first Tom
Cruise movie went into production but
none of them appeared in the film as it
turns out they weren't happy with how
the story was updated as Martin Landau
said to MTV News when they were working
on an early incarnation of the first one
not the scripts they ultimately did they
wanted the entire team to be destroyed
done away worth one at a time and I was
against that it was basically an
action-adventure movie and not mission
mission was a mind game the ideal
mission was getting in and out without
anyone ever knowing we were there so the
whole texture changed Peter Graves
wasn't happy with the movie either
especially considering his character Jim
Phelps was turned into a villain the
actor told CNN I am sorry that they
chose to call him Phelps they could have
solved that very easily by either having
me in a scene from the very beginning or
reading a telegram from me saying hey
boys I'm retired gone to Hawaii thank
you goodbye you take over now another
original member of the mission team
Craig Morris reports that he saw the
final product and walked out of him the
90s saw the beginning of the CGI ERA
with computer effects rapidly replacing
real sets and practical photography as
filmmakers gain the ability to create
entire worlds through the power of
digital technology of course virtual
sets are commonplace in movies today but
the first mission impossible helps
Pioneer them in 1996. Virtual sets took
a big step forward for an action segment
in which Tom Cruise and Jon Voight fight
on top of the channel tunnel train as
industrial lights and Magic VFX
supervisor John Knoll explained we took
blue screen elements of actors and put
them into believable CG backgrounds Cruz
is going for more realism with his
stunts these days and perhaps he would
want to film that segment shot on top of
a real train today still this segment in
Mission Impossible was a big step
forward opening the door for practically
any mind-blowing action segment a
director can come up with without the
limitations of imagination physics or
reality oh boy even if you don't know
the name Alan cielvestri you certainly
know his music because he wrote the
iconic theme to back to the future he
was also set to be the original composer
on the first mission impossible movie
but he was replaced by Danny Elfman
Elfman had five weeks to write and
record a new score but as he explained
to soundtrack magazine anybody coming in
second has a huge advantage of
understanding what the director doesn't
want at the expense of a loss of work
already put in I knew that they wanted
energy they wanted something a little
more operatic and Theatrical just seeing
the movie without a score for Mission
Impossible 2 Metallica contributed I
disappear and when the sun leaked onto
Napster it changed the landscape of the
music industry forever in a landmark
case Metallica suit Napster over the
league in 2000 however the file sharing
Genie was already out of the bottle and
the stage was set for downloads and
eventually streaming to become a huge
part of how people listen to music
throughout Hollywood history actors have
produced their own films started their
own production companies and in the case
of United Artists even launched their
own Studio Tom Cruise became his own
producer on the first mission impossible
and this has made him very rich
as variety reported Cruz is taking less
money up front for the next Mission
Impossible movies but he's getting a big
chunk of the movie's first dollar gross
this means that he'll be taking home
sizable bonuses even before the studio
gets a full return on its investment
whereas a star normally has to wait for
the film's final backend crows to be
tallied before they get a piece of the
action cruises deal for top gun Maverick
means he can make upwards of 100 million
dollars and he's certain to make a
truckload of cash on future Mission
films as well the mission impossible
films have always been known for their
stunning action sequences and the
filmmakers know well enough by now to
put particular focus on delivering the
goods with each new installment
sometimes in fact the stories are built
around action scenes rather than the
other way around the sole credited
screenwriter for Mission Impossible 2
Robert towney had words with the crews
previously on Days of Thunder and the
firm townie had worked as a script
doctor on a number of films including
Bonnie and Clyde and The Godfather so he
knew how to come in and deliver great
scenes when a movie needed help but
writing a movie around the action scenes
was something he'd never experienced
before as Tony told creative
screenwriting they said these are the
action scenes what do you think of
coming up with a story to fit them I
said it was an insane idea but I did it
Tony finally came up with the key to the
story from researching viruses then the
idea dawned on him what about a villain
who creates a deadly virus so he can
make a fortune selling the antidote it's
a chilling idea for an action film and
it would be even more scary today in a
post-covered world a lot goes into a
movie and with Mission Impossible
fallouts but Quarry told the world in an
Instagram post just what challenges went
into making the movie the filmmaker
posted the following three thousand
setups 13 helicopters six pregnancies
five hiatuses four weeks of aerial
photography three continents two Winters
one broken ankle that's a wrap the
broken ankle belonged to Cruz who was
injured in a stunt as Cruz explained on
The Tonight Show he was supposed to be
running and jumping across buildings
when the accidents happened according to
reports by far out Cruz was back in
Action seven weeks after his injury as
to why he does his own stunts he
explained it has to do with storytelling
it allows us to put cameras in places
that you're not normally able to do Cruz
explained how the first time attempting
a stunt is equal past anxiety and
adrenaline he mentioned how others tell
him he's got a huge grin on his face
while shooting these dangerous sequences
here is why Tom Cruise gets paid the big
bucks okay
that's Mission Impossible dead reckoning
power one was being hyped at Cinema Khan
2022 in Vegas but Quarry promised the
film will feature the most dangerous
stunts the team has ever attempted in
order to pull this stunt off Crews
needed 500 hours of skydiving training
and he had to perform 13 000 bike jumps
to nail The Landing perfectly beyond the
stunts the mission impossible shoot was
also dangerous because of the pandemic
crews in particular made headlines for
some heated exchangers with crew members
who failed to follow a strict masking
mandate Cruiser McCrory also both
reportedly caught the virus while
Macquarie had to be hospitalized
apparently Cruisers had the urge for
dangerous stunts since he was a kid he
revealed that the Cannes Film Festival
that he jumped off his roof when he was
four years old making a parachute out of
a sheet the actor described how he
recognized it was a bad idea as soon as
he leapt describing how he feared dying
from the fall or his mother killing him
for doing it since covert hit the movie
industry has been on Shaky Ground a
number of movies were delayed
Productions were shut down and many were
scared that streaming would wipe out the
theater going experience as the industry
attempts to settle into a new normal Tom
Cruise is hoping he can save theaters
with top gun Maverick and the upcoming
Mission Impossible movies the next
mission films will be released in two
parts and Crews set up Top Gun to have a
90-day theatrical window giving it as
much time as possible to make money at
the box office Crews initially wanted
Maverick to have a 120-day theatrical
run before the movie went to streaming
and other secondary markets but Studio
negotiations whittled that down to 90.
Forbes speculated that Cruz could use
the success of Maverick as a bargaining
chip for release terms on the next two
Mission films which could also play a
big hand in Saving the theatrical
experience for movie fans as Cruz
himself wrote on Instagram 36 years
after the first film top gun Maverick is
here we made it for the big screen and
we made it for you the fans I hope you
enjoy the ride this weekend other kind
Film Festival Cruise wins on record to
say that he wants to make movies for the
theater experience and so that people
can go out and watch them he went on to
promise that Maverick never would have
been released direct to a streaming
platform he believes a movie should
always be experienced in a theater as
it's something special people can share
with the others around them and partake
in the collective excitement